nul n'est censé ignorer la loi et
surtout pas les députés pourtant
aujourd'hui placardées dans les
ascenseurs de l'assemblée ces
affichettes reproduisent en deux
articles du code pénal sur le
harcèlement sexuel et moral
un rappel qui intervient alors que
plusieurs signalements sont en cours à
l'assemblée depuis plusieurs semaines
les témoignages d'assistante
parlementaire affluent l'un de ces
députés incriminés juge malgré tout
cette campagne d'affichage assez inutile
le coma qui a été engagé par les femmes
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire je sais
pas dans cette attitude mais est naturel
et légitime
c'est pas la peine maintenant du juin de
mendoza mettre partout le placard et
partout des anciennes attachées
parlementaires des élus une journaliste
vous ont accusé de d'agression sexuelle
et de harcèlement aucune plainte n'a été
déposée contre vous cependant est-ce que
vous reconnaissez avoir eu des des
comportements inappropriés
non je cracherais pas vous dire comme à
beaucoup cassé les couilles avec ça
et j'en ai vomi de la bile ce qui ne
m'était jamais arrivé j'avais lu que
napoléon et vomit de la bile lorsqu'il
avait appris la déroute de soult geale
sont en espagne jamais je n'aurais cru
que la faire comme ça a pu m'arriver
je n'ai jamais fait ça j'ai beaucoup
aimé les femmes lorsque juste sorti de
ma timidité mais je tiens g a rappelé
que j'avais une légitime parisienne en
génération de parisiens suivant qui va
fait quatre beaux enfants à lourdios
ichère
alors que j'aime passionnément
ensuite il n'y a que deux sexes forte
heureusement comme je l'avais dit une
fois
je n'avais jamais compris mon père n'a
jamais appris que les gars
pour une femme lui tenir la porte lui
fait un compliment était quelque chose
de répréhensible
[Musique]